the smell of fire and oil fills the air
the sound of gears grinding can be heard
between the explosions and shrieks of
terror
a man runs out of his house only to have
his leg grabbed by a metal arm and
dragged back through his front door
scp-001 leaves a trail of metal
fragments and mechanical parts on the
ground in the wake of its destruction
iron chains swing from its form cast
iron gears whirl within it
a glowing light throbs from the center
of its body
scp-001 is consuming everything
in its path after incorporating the
truck chassis into its being
scp-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion to
the next house it rips the gutters from
the side of the building
residents who live in the area flee
their neighborhood all the while hoping
that the mechanical monstrosity skips
over their house
so they have something to return to if
they make it out alive
a section of scp-001's undercarriage
drops away from the main body
it rolls down the street consuming more
and more material
the new entity resembles a human spine
and ribcage
it topples over unable to support itself
the rib-like formations extend out to
grab
anything and everything within reach the
newly incorporated material forms what
can only be described as a head
light from within the eye sockets fixate
on nearby civilians
the metallic creature picks up the
people and places them inside its
exposed steel rib cage
then it turns and spots a woman
helplessly trying to crawl away
the creature reaches out with a spiked
tentacle and wraps it around the woman's
body
she is placed inside of the chest cavity
moments later
a severed hand falls out of the entity
and onto the ground
the mechanical monster continues to
gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand
on its back it becomes so massive that
the creature falls over and uses its
limbs to scurry to a nearby house
there is a sickening crunching sound as
the growth bursts
from within emerges three humanoid
creatures resembling the civilians that
the entity had consumed earlier
a female with chains extending from her
scalp like dreadlocks stumbles away
the second humanoid is a man with cogs
for limbs
he examines the clock-like components
that have been incorporated into his
body
then stares blankly into the distance
the third humanoid lies motionless on
the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically
the half-human half-machine humanoids
turn and run away
from the mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as
scp-001 the foundation had been in
contact with the allied occult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in mexico
being worshipped by a group of people
who identified themselves as the church
of the broken god
intel about the church claimed their
deity was a small mechanical box filled
with cogs and pistons
the box supposedly had supernatural
abilities it was said to be able to
communicate with congregants of the
church of the broken god telepathically
the devout worship the box following any
order it gave
and in return they were filled with an
emotion that could be only described
as divine as world war ii rages on in
europe
the foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in mexico that might help with
the war effort
while there the foundation force is
tasked with learning about the church of
the broken god
they are also ordered to investigate a
town near la paz where there are
troubling accounts of a mechanical
anomalous creature causing mayhem
the agents make their way through mexico
gathering various objects to bring back
to foundation sites in the united
states the unit loads all the anomalies
they recovered onto a train
with a plan to check out the stories of
the mechanical anomaly they've heard
about
as they make their way to the us border
the train heads north along rusted rails
just outside la paz they've come across
a broken down train
filled with what looks to be refugees
when the foundation unit goes to
investigate
they find all the refugees repeating the
same words over and over again
but they don't understand the foundation
agents look at one another confused
until one of them translates the words
into english the words the refugees are
saying
over and over again are la machina the
machine
the commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks
to see if they can figure out what has
the refugees so scared
they make their way towards la paz
disappearing over the horizon
as the sun sets the remaining foundation
agents hear gunshots in the distance
they stay awake all night
remaining vigilant waiting for the
exploratory squad
but morning comes without anyone
returning three days later the
foundation force still has not seen
anything since the exploratory squad
left
then as the sun sits lazily in the
morning sky
a lone figure is spotted walking down
the tracks towards the trains
one of the agents on watch blows his
whistle and points to the figure
a squad of agents rushes towards the
shadow of a man their guns are raised
ready for anything
the figure drops to the ground and
begins to crawl along the tracks
the agents reach the fallen man only to
find that he is one of their squad mates
who has been sent up the tracks to
investigate la paz
several days before the agent's name is
demarco
he is covered in blood his clothes are
in tatters and he has lost a boot
demarco lies on his back with foundation
agents standing around him
his eyes are wide and wild he keeps
babbling on about a world eater
how the rest of his squad had been
mulched and he is the only one who made
it out alive
the foundation agents carried demarco
back to the makeshift base they created
by the trains
they need to figure out a way to get the
convoy moving again but whatever is up
ahead has already taken out an
entire foundation squad it had to be
something anomalous
but what could it possibly be the unit
of foundation agents prepare to move
towards la paz
they start loading their rifles and
check the amount of ammunition and
explosives available
in case the containment process gets out
of hand just as they are about to leave
the base
a convoy appears on the horizon it is an
allied occult initiative force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is
devastating la paz
this organization's mission is to not
secure contain
or protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the joint force with the allied
occult initiative may be the only way to
stop what is now known as
scp-001 the aoi
and foundation force gears up for battle
they set out for la paz
and what they find causes them to quake
with fear
scp-001 has consumed so much material
it is the size of a mountain it moves
like a tidal wave of mechanical
destruction
washing over the buildings and landscape
under it whatever scp-001 passes over is
consumed and added to its massive body
scp-001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal death machine
the church of the broken god has finally
met their maker
as the small entity they once worshipped
has now consumed
all of its members their god is an
all-consuming
monster the aoi and foundation forces do
everything they can to stop
scp-001 from continuing its reign of
destruction
they fire barrage after barrage of
bullets and explosives
into the mechanical anomaly they bring
in air support to try and damage it from
the skies
but nothing works the aoi uses an
artifact in their possession to lure
scp-001 to the coast of the pacific
ocean
where a trap has been set for the
so-called god the monstrous mechanical
creature moves slowly towards the water
it consumes abandoned cars buildings and
boats as it approaches the coastline
it even shovels large amounts of earth
into its form
causing flames to spurt out from its
inner workings
smoke bellows from openings between
different mechanical components
like a volcano before it is about to
erupt suddenly
seemingly from nowhere a massive cloud
with a reddish tint appears in the sky
air raid sirens can be heard in the
distance the enormous cloud begins to
pulsate
streaks of lightning shoot through the
red mist in the sky it now sits directly
over scp-001
from within the cloud part of a ship can
be seen it appears to be slightly
damaged
electricity flows over its home the
vessel in the giant red cloud is
classified as
scp-2399 the underside of the vessel
begins to glow
aqua blue a blinding beam of light is
ejected from scp-2399 which penetrates
straight down and through
scp-001 for a moment
everything is still there is complete
silence
then as if scp-001 is trying to reach up
and grab the vessel above it
a mechanical bulge reaches out before
scp-001 can grab the vessel above
there is another bright flash of light
scp-2399 blinks out of existence
the sound of grinding gears can be heard
coming from within scp-001
it begins to shed its outer layers of
metal then the entire structure that was
scp-001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach
giant cogs fall from the sky parts of
vehicles embed themselves in the sand
as the foundation and aoi agents
approach the piles of scrap metal and
mechanical components
they see that some of them are still
moving it is as if an invisible power
source is still
pulsating through some of the machinery
the agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast
but little do they know this was only a
piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken god the foundation agents
collect as many of the still-moving
parts as they can
they find spinning gears twitching
pulleys and firing pistons
as the parts are separated from one
another and carried away from the main
wreckage of scp-001
they slowly stop moving and become
inactive some of the artifacts were
covered were identified as being
connected to the church of the broken
god
these artifacts are found closer to the
middle of what was once a mountain-sized
scp-001
hundreds of anomalous artifacts are
collected and transported to scp
foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of scp-001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving parts
getting caught in them and losing a body
part or two but most agents proceed with
caution
and survived the collection ordeal with
their arms and legs still attached to
their bodies
dive teams are sent into the water to
recover parts that have sunk to the
bottom of the sea
one of the divers is a local from the
area he is hired to bring up the heart
of the machine
since he is an experienced diver used to
free diving to great depths to collect
oysters from the bottom of the bay
the diver enters the water and swims
down into the murky depths
he secures straps around the heart of
scp-001 and pulls hard on the rope
as an indication to the surface that it
is ready to be hauled up
the salvage team on the surface begins
to pull there is a second slight tug on
the rope
then it goes slack the team continues to
pull when they get the heart to the
surface
they are horrified at what else comes up
with it
tangled in the ropes is the lifeless
body of the diver
his head is smashed between two moving
pieces of the heart
it looks as if he shoved his head
between the slabs of metal
himself the salvage team untangles the
body
rolls it off the deck and back into the
ocean the mechanical box which was the
heart of scp-001 is offloaded on the
shore
but as the foundation prepares to move
it to a containment facility
the weather starts to deteriorate
hurricane force wind sweeps across the
water and batter the coast
the heart is kept in a secured storage
warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off
once the storm passes the foundation
agents load the heart onto a ship
it is to be transported to a foundation
site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and serene the
foundation ship
undocks and begins its journey up the
coast not too long after beginning its
journey the ship slowly drifts off
course
it is as if the crew has stopped manning
their posts and the ship is being
controlled by a mind of its own
the foundation ship crashes and sinks
somewhere in the pacific ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of scp-001
doesn't make it to the foundation site
years later a man is walking along the
beach
he hears something it sounds like
someone pounding on a large drum to the
rhythm of a heartbeat
the man walks towards the sound
something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand
the man digs deeper and pulls out the
small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing
he holds the box close to his own heart
it seems
to speak to him the man brings the box
back to town
he starts to worship the box and soon
more and more people in the area join
the new religion
they cast aside their own beliefs and
focus on the powerful entity
contained within the box god is not dead
at least not yet but the prophecies of
the church of the broken god
say that when the heart is found the god
will reassemble itself
once again then the unbroken god will
destroy
all other false deities until only
he remains now go watch another scp-001
proposal the children or scp-2935-o
death for more stories from the scp
foundation that you have to see
to believe